because it didn't. This is what it looks like, right? This is
what it looks like perfectly from top down. You think there aren't
angles where you like can't really tell what this is and you
was okay. You're that like that's every angle that he looked
at it when he held it and posed for a picture. Yes. Yes. You
understand? You're making a positive claim, right? You're making
a positive claim. You have to prove it in some way, but you don't
want to prove it, right? You you just want to I think I would
probably say that you're playing into anti-semitism into that.
No. No. No. If you're being if you're being completely histrionic,
I can laugh at you. Sorry. If you are being completely insane
about anti-semitism, if you are seeing Jew haters behind every
corner, I will make fun of you. You deserve to be made fun of.
I don't have to plate your insane fantasies about anti-semitic
people coming to burn down your house. I don't have to do that.
That's not a rule, okay? And I will do that. If you're being
insane, I'm sorry. I'm going to call you out and laugh at you.
That's not anti-semitism. Laughing at people who are completely
hallucinating anti-semitism is not in itself anti-semitism. Welcome.
Welcome. How's it going? Hello. I'm good. Okay. I don't know
your uh I guess maybe I don't know your position. Why do you
think uh Ian picked that sword? What's my position on the sword
or what? Why do you think I Sorry. Why do you think Ian picked
that sword? Cuz it was sitting there. It was sitting there cuz
Were there Were there like were there like eight swords to choose
from and he chose the Nazi sword? Did he have to pick a sword?
I mean, you you're hanging out in someone's room with like cool
and you're like, "Can I use a sword or something?" Yeah. They're
all just being goofy. Okay. How do you square that with You said
earlier that it's like a air horn. Like, it's so obvious that
it's a swastika
because if you were because you called it a dog whistle because
you tried to call it a dog whistle. It's not It wouldn't be a
dog whistle. It would just be like this is this is a swastika
sword. Did I not notice that? Wait, but you you know it's not
actually swastika, right? You know that that's like not actually
what it is. Okay. Like um what do you mean? Like it's reverse.
I I from what I understand it's like reverse and it's like a
is the symbol mangi or something. It's like a Buddhist symbol
for for life or something. I
forget. Symbol. Okay. Um it's like reverse like the Nazis took
it and reversed it. Right. Sure. Oh, okay. I haven't watched
Bleach though. I just have a friend that watched Bleach told
me this. So the sword is uh called what? The Zangatsu. Um, and
it's like the main character's granddad and his granddad is like
the uh king of the quincies. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I've I've looked
into that. Sure. Yeah. And um they're like do those are like
really obviously supposed to be Nazis, right? Do you think the
Do you think the author knew that was going to happen when he
first wrote drove drew the sword? Um I don't know. You'd have
to know at like how legendarily bad at story structure the author
of Bleach is. And this was like three, five years later after
the start of the story that the the grandfather was introduced.
Maybe more than five years. Might be like eight years. Like this
was this was not an intended aspect of this in like anyway, just
so you know. Um like I I'm I will make that argument. I would
make that argument. If the author told me he was doing it intentionally,
I would not believe him. But I I'm still like I watched a little
bit of Bleach. I read it when I was a kid and I was like very
I read it and it got so bad that I had to stop. Um, but um, okay.
I could I could believe that. But does that actually matter when
you're uh presenting to a Western audience? Like no one here
no one here is Japanese and no one's confusing that with the
Japanese symbol. Every single person interprets it as a swastika.
Sure. So like some people have started a nefarious rumor about
me online at one point in time that painted me as anti-semitic.
So I might not buy that sword cuz I can look at it. I'm like,
"Oh, I don't really want to give off that vibe." But if you're
somebody who is like basically constantly arguing about how evil
Nazis are, I could see how you would buy that sword and not really
be concerned about that because it would be insane for anybody
to think that you're actually a covert like crypto Nazi. Maybe
for him buying it, but what about using it when uh what about
like using it for the shot? I I don't know that that would maybe
be the the worst thing you could accuse them of is you could
try to mind readad them and say, "Oh, Ethan's Ethan's angry."
Oh, sorry. Did you not hear anything? cow. Cool. No, I'm sorry.
I think the worst thing you could argue about them or say about
them is actually
Idubbbz grabbed that sword and then after they saw the shot,
he was like, "No, keep it in because Ethan's like being a histrionic
Jew or something that but that like requires a mind readading."
And like Idubbbz basically gave up his edgy platform, gave up
saying the nword, gave up like millions of views every month,
right? Or every couple weeks or however often he was uh publishing,
right? He basically nuked his career to be like, I don't think
being edgy is cool. I don't think I don't believe in these things.
And then he his like wife is a huge, you know, tanky like politically.
I the idea that these people are like covert Nazis or trying
to use like a Nazi symbol to go after Ethan when they have like
85 different reasons to hate Ethan that have nothing to do with
Nazis. The point is to it would you wouldn't be being a Nazi.
The point is to like the idea is to try to provoke Ethan saying
he's like so paranoid. Uh, okay. It's like this like it's like
the same things like all bright people would do where they just
do the like dumb dog whistles and then oh my god all the liberals
are so obsessed. You understand you understand the strategy for
that is to not be baited by the dog whistle, right? To just ask
them what they mean. Sure. You understand that that is actually
effective, right? So then you would say that it is a dog whistle.
Nope. But but like it literally doesn't matter. How do you deal
with dog whistles? Because the strategy is the same either way.
If it's not a dog whistle, you handle it the same way. Why? Why
strategy matter? That's not what the strategy is.
Well, I'm talking about the strategy for handling both that you
look history. I'm talking about what it is. You get freaked out
about stuff.
Okay. Like just had this sword, right? You're aware that he's
used it for other promotional materials and stuff, right? Yeah.
Like if I pull this up on the stream, you've seen that he used
this for like a I saw the Creed's ad. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Was dog
whistling here? Uh no, probably not. Okay. So just because a
Jew was involved in the content piece, this is now a dog whistle.
Um, no, it's because it's the context of the thing he's using
it for is with the uh the context of the drama is they're all
they're being accused of anti-semitism. So when you pull it out
there, Yeah. which is insane. Okay. So then yes, that context
would change it. Yeah. Okay. I mean, okay, they're being accused
of I don't know if has Ethan accused Idubbbz of anti-semitism.
Um, well, they're all together. Why? Why? What do you mean? Why
are they all together? Because they decided to be like I mean
like Ian Assan Denims all those people basically not made any
public statements about this stuff, right? I'm saying they're
physically together in that room. Okay. So you think Ian went,
"Well, I know that Ethan has accused some of these people of
anti-semitism, so I'm going to grab grab this sword with a swastika
to bait him into being like a coveting Jew over it." You think
that's what went through his head? No, I mean um it doesn't have
to be. I mean one of their heads maybe. Probably. Yeah. Okay.
We're like, "Yeah." So, like all of these people who are super
anti-Nazi were like, "Yeah, this is the line. We're we're going
to actually principally
Hold on. Hold on. Wait. Wait. I got to clear. Yeah. They're in
fact principally anti-Nazi. Yes. But hold on just real quick.
You will say, you just asked a question that was insane, right?
They're obviously principally anti-Nazi. Every single one who's
involved in that video, please just admit that they're obviously
principally anti-Nazi. All right. Sorry. Did your Discord crash
again? Hello. His Discord must have crashed again. This guy's
having a rough time with the Discords now. He sounds like Carrier.
At first he sounded kind of like Aiden, but now he sounds uh
now he sounds like Carrier a little bit. Oh, are you back? Hello.
You're kind of breaking up quite a bit.
Doing like the thing that Sorry. You You totally cut out. I think
we got to reset here.
Yeah, you totally cut out. I think we got to reset a little bit
here. So, what was the last thing you heard me say? I was saying,
could you just admit that they're principally anti-Nazi?
Like that communists would be principally anti-Nazi, obviously.
Oh, I didn't hear that. Um They're principally like these people
are all principally anti-Nazi cuz you asked if they were and
they are obviously principally anti-Nazi
like I guess okay connections really depends on what aspect of
what you're trying cutting in and out a lot. I'm going to give
you some time to figure this out. But all sorry you're do you
want to maybe try restarting Discord? I'm not totally sure. Like
maybe reconnecting to the waiting room or something. I don't
know. I'm not sure what's going on here. Oh, hold on. It's not
him, guys. It's not him. It's Discord. Discord's up. Hold on.
Give me a second. I'll switch this the region on this. Let me
go like this. Will that reconnect us automatically? Okay. Uh
Discord was up. So I just set us to a different region. So hopefully
it will stop. This wasn't you. It was uh it was just Discord.
Okay. Okay. So they're they're not they're principally anti-Nazi,
right? They're like tanky communist coded people. They're principally
anti-Nazi was what I was saying. Um okay. Okay. I don't know
if they pick Okay. What I'm saying is um Okay. The like everything
together like Sure. I'm like they're probably like really against
the white supremacy part, but like every part of Nazism they're
probably not principally against. Like I don't know if they're
principally against anti-semitism. Okay. But then you could just
call them anti-semitic. They are principally against Nazism.
Okay. Sure. Like fascism like literally their their predicate
their their like pretext for hating Israel is that it's basically
like um like a pseudo-Nazi regime, right? like it's a it's an
ethnosentric country that is purported purportedly I don't believe
this committing a genocide against the Palestinians right like
it it is literally that is why they hate that is their justification
for hating Israel is like the justification the Nazis used to
exist and create a party and take over their country okay
I just say probably for your argumentation it looks really bad
if you try to call them Nazis because they're just clearly not
I didn't I never said they were Nazis I yeah but you said do
you think they're principally anti-Nazi as in We were questioning
it. I'm sorry. I forgot why I said that. I forget both. Okay.
Where am I? Do you? I don't know. Sorry. We were arguing basically.
I'm like, I don't think this is a dog whistle. I don't think
dog whistling here. I don't think Idubbbz is dog whistling over
there. I think they're principally anti-Nazi. I think the worst
you could accuse them of is going I bet this would freak e Ethan
out. I bet Ethan would that would that's just that's which would
just be like the dog whistling thing. That would just be it wouldn't
be dog whistling the ideology.
I'm saying that like you have to mind read that and then a group
of people who are all like principally anti-Nazi going yeah we
should use this swast to go to with the Jewish guy.
Yeah. Is there another reading that is they just grabbed the
sword and didn't care. They didn't care about the really obvious
symbol and then when called out on it they never they didn't
even deny it. They can't actually say oh I didn't this was misunderstanding.
He always like, "Oh yeah, I did it." Like as a joke. When when
being in good faith with these people changed something they
did, this guy came out and immediately denounced like the whole
CPS thing and he's still being like publicly maligned for being
like anti-Semitic and hateful towards Ethan. But he went out
the second that happened was like, "Guys, come on. You can't
nobody call CPS. That's insane. Never once never once got any
significant amount of credit for it or anything. Why would he
Why would he care to be like sensitive to anybody else? Why would
he care to like try to try to plate somebody else? I just don't
get it. Also, Assan is bad. Does he not care? I guess if he doesn't
care about um looking anti really looking really obviously anti-Semitic,
then I to the people who are already calling him anti-Semitic.
I I guess and only those people. Well, okay. Only those people.
I I think like most normie people are looking at that. No, you
you guys have to understand that to normie people, you guys are
getting brutally by he looks, you have this is actually what
pisses me off maybe the most. Okay, I was a very effective propagandist
when I was doing the propaganda against this guy was into the
dirt and now he's back and he looks so cool when you guys cavet
about the swastika sword. He got to do his whole like light impression
yesterday. He did his whole meme and he looks so cool and it's
You guys, you guys suck at propaganda now. It sucks. Maybe to
internet. I don't Maybe I just I would guess that only Only if
you're like a really edgy person would you think that was cool.
But I don't know. I mean, no. Sorry. He looks cool because he
just had a bleach sword. And everybody's like, "Oh my god, you're
trying to be anti-Semitic. You're sending anti-semitic dog whistles."
And he's like, "Yeah, I cleverly bought this bleach sword three
years ago and have used it like eight different times because
I knew that my my my current best friend and podcast host, okay,
podcast co-host would eventually betray me and then I could use
this to rile him up because he's Jewish." Like that's that's
lit. He got to go do his whole bit and he got to like make everybody
else look ridiculous and he totally won. I guess strategically
I'm just talking Okay, I'm not thinking about like the strategy.
I'm just thinking about like what he's doing. Um, and the fact
like it's um it's not an optical thing. It's that if he was genuinely
like, "Oh, that was an actual misunderstanding." You would think
that he would say that ever, but he doesn't because it's not
a misunderstanding and he keeps doing the he keeps doing the
bit of like, "Isn't Ian so crazy?" or sorry, Ethan so crazy because
that was the point.
Apparently went while Ethan was live and kept asking him to chat.
Ethan, can we just talk about this? Ethan, can we just talk?
Ethan refused. Uhoh. O. Uhoh. Is uh chasing. Oh, is he's looking
pretty good right now. I'm not going to lie to you. Anyway, uh
you're saying like could this be like that they're with Ethan
with that? I mean, technically um they could be totally non-principled
and be doing that, but the more likely explanation is nobody
really cared and then they were like, "Oh, it's a swastika sword
or something." And then they just looked at it and were like,
"Oh, it's not really a swastika though. It's like all different
shaped and just did the bit and just don't care." Do you think
they they were like, "Okay, hold on. Hold on. What angle is it?
I remember the angle." "Oh, it's clearly not a swastika because
it's like the different direction." Like, no one thinks like
that. It's It's also not like squarely shaped. It's not evenly
shaped or anything. How? Okay. It's just everyone interpreted
it that way immediately. Okay. You're saying everyone interpreted
it that way? I I think basically nobody interprets it that way,
but hey, it's fine. Like there's a there's a reason why there's
a controversy about it. It's a bunch of people interpreting it
that way. Yeah. It's totally manufactured by people who have
a who have a specific aligned interest. It's just bad faith.
And I guess Yeah. True. What What do I even say? True. Okay.
Show me Show me like a neutral party who's very upset about this.
Show me a a person around. If they're upset, then they're not
a neutral party anymore. So, I guess I can't. No, no, no. Show
me Show me somebody who doesn't hate who's like, "Oh, wow. This
is really weird."
Um, I'm not familiar with every influencer. I guess I'm guessing
most people would pick their sides. I don't know why this would
really be the thing to move anyone over either. Oh, apparently
Ethan wants I don't know why that would even be relevant. Maybe
I got bad information. I don't know. Yeah, I just I I'm saying
there had to be people who basically would switch. I I feel like
if this was actually um as bad as you say, somebody would get
like mad about it. But I just can't see anybody who's actually
mad about it. Well, except all the people that don't like him.
Yeah. people who like have been calling anti-semitic the whole
time. Yeah. I don't I don't know how that proves that they're
bad faith. It doesn't prove that they're bad faith. I'm just
saying that like I mean there's there's an obvious explanation,
right? And the simplest explanation is they just use a sword
that was there cuz son owned it. Um obviously knows that that
could look like a swastika, but it's just probably not something
that ever occupies his brain space because he's he's using his
bleach sword, right? Like he he's just using his sword. He doesn't
really care. Like that's You're just describing what happened,
but you're just you also they also have to be like
they have to be like, "Oh, you know, this looks like a swastika,
but I don't care." Or, "I just I can't possibly figure out how
anyone could see this as a swastika."
Why? Why should he care when they're already calling him anti-semitic?
Why should he go, "Well, no, no, no. We can't use that sword
cuz it counts. He can just be anti-semitic if he wants, I guess."
But that's not why Wait, why is it anti-semitic to just use the
sword that's in the room? Yes, I understand. I understand. You
can say like why should he care about not appearing anti-semitic,
but then like okay, I don't understand how that is a defense.
Don't switch to saying he's anti-Semitic. You're saying he appears
anti-mitic. People are already calling him anti-Semitic. No,
the first thing you said was he's being anti-Semitic then. And
he might appear anti-mitic to people who already think he's anti-Semitic,
but that's already why should he why should he appeal or why
should he try to appease? What use is there in that? It's I'm
not talking about appeasing them. It's just like doing the thing.
Like you're just saying like he could just be anti-semitic and
that would just be bass. You just gig chat. Every single person
who's calling him anti-semitic for the sword who's who's caveting
about the sword was kveting about him literally like talking
about not happening, right? They were all they were all like
uh what do you call misusing clips of him from like the Richie
Torres guy and they're all calling him anti-semitic anyway. Why
does it matter? This is like such this is like so much less bad
than the the doubts of the on October 7th. Why would this even
register in his mind? Okay. He could als he could be anti-semitic
and they would also react the same way. Does that mean he's not
anti-Semitic?
Sure. But then you'd have say Hitler and I guess like they would
uh they would all be mad about it. No, if he said Hal Hitler
that would obviously be a totally different thing. Okay. But
all the how all the same people are mad about it because the
literal explanation of this symbol being used is not anti-Semitic.
It's not in a swastika and people are just blowing it up because
it's it's literally a sword from an anime that he's used in multiple
other things. Right? If he said Hy Hitler, there's no reason
like this would be the equivalent of he's reading an article
that says Hy Hitler in it and he reads that and you clip it and
go, "Oh my god, he's being anti-semitic. Why did he read that
line? Why did he read the line? Doesn't he know that we could
think that's anti-Semitic?" That's what you guys are doing. which
is fine if you want to be like if you want to be every stereotype
that's fine. He's okay. He's posing with the sword with the in
the picture. It's not just like randomly. It's not that he owns
the sword is the problem. We've admitted that the sword symbol
is not a swastika, right? It is in fact the the the Buddha symbol.
It comes across as swastika to everyone that matters. It it like
Okay, but I'm trying to I'm trying to like that% in a context
that makes sense to you. Okay, it definitely matters because
it is definitely like the actual context. Okay, it's then if
says Hal Hitler while reading the article, does the context not
matter? He's saying Hal Hitler. He's saying the words. Does the
context not matter at all? The symbols inherently don't matter.
It's how they're how they're interpreted by other people. Okay.
So,
however, then prevalent does that interpretation have to be?
How prevalent does that interpretation have to be
for us to go? Not a single there's not a single good faith person
in the west that is like that seriously think like oh I don't
know I was just a Buddhist peace symbol. Sure we all saw we all
saw when in we all saw when he takes his headband off in Nudo
and we're like oh my god is that a swastika and then some person
comes along and they're like actually no it's like the reversed
uh mangi mangji symbol. Go ahead. I don't know why I said that
himself sees it as a swastika. So why does it matter? He thinks
it could look like a swastika. Yeah, he thinks it does look He
called it the swaska sword. Why did he say that? Because he understands
that people could see it that way. Okay. So, he understands that
people could see it that way. So, he's using symbolism to communicate
anyway
it. Okay. Yeah. Okay. Sure. So, you're arguing that the the famous
socialist, the guy who's only ever voted for leftists and who
is universally at all times been against people like Nick Fuentes,
anybody who's remotely uh Nazi adjacent, he's been against them
his entire career, has actually been faking that the entire time
so he could dog whistle to towards Nazism with a swastika sword
or it's just a funny joke cuz it's a bleach sword that sort of
looks like it. It might have a swastika on it. Oh, wait. It's
the second thing. It's that's Yeah, you just described it. It's
a funny joke cuz like Ethan is just like this crazy paranoid
Jew who is afraid of anti-semitism. So I'm just going to sneak
in little things. Yeah. Or it's just it's the sword in his room.
That's what he did. It's the sword in his room. That's why I'm
saying the picture video about how it's You understand that a
dog whistle requires the underlying belief, right? You understand
that there are people who say Christ is king with no understanding
of the internet or the fact that that's been used to like sort
of as a it's okay to be white thing, right? that you require
the underlying belief to call it a dog whistle or else you're
It's okay. I guess you can call it something else. It's um the
point is to bait. I guess you just call it bait. Yeah, that would
be a better word. Okay. Uh you could argue he's doing it to bait
Ethan, but you'll never be able to prove that. And you look insane
if he's using it to bait Ethan. Okay. It's just the only only
interpretation that makes any sense. But I mean, no. The other
interpretation that makes way more sense is, hey, we want to
have a sword. We're doing a group picture. Hey, that sword looks
cool. Can I use that? The sword I recognize as a swastika sword.
I'm sure they'll be Do you know who was in the room when Idubbbz
grabbed it? Do you know who was in the room when Idubbbz was
like, I'm going to use this? And he was like, no, wait, don't
do that. It's a swastika sword. Did was Idubbbz aware it was
a swastika sword? Was Idubbbz aware that like the sword from
Bleach? Did Idubs know anything about it or did he just grab
the sword? Was it not in the picture? He was in the Well, I thought
he was in the picture, but if he wasn't in the picture, I'm saying
that like when Idubbbz grabbed it, do you know he was in the
room? Or did Idubs grab it and Hassan walks back into the room
and he's like, "Oh, oh, Hassan's not in the picture apparently."
Hold on. There's no way Hassan's not in the picture. Idubbbz
sword content cop. Does anybody have the picture? There's no
way that isn't in the picture. Hold on. Where's the picture?
Where's the picture? Somebody liked the picture right now. Somebody
like it right now. Where is it? There's no way not in it. Can
I go to images? We get the sword here. Oh, it's him with the
sword. Jesus Christ, that keyboard's loud. Okay, so that's Is
this the picture we're talking about? There's no other picture
here. Oh, I guess he was into that. Um, okay. I'm sorry. You're
arguing that had no input at all. I don't know. I'm not making
arguments because I'm not They're in his house. They're I'm not
making arguments cuz I don't have an interest here. I guess maybe
that could be the case. This feels incredibly unbelievably unlikely.
There has to be There has to be a picture with in it, right?
There has to be. Okay. I'm sorry. By the way, do you think that
like they're just all completely oblivious that this looks like
a swastika? I don't I literally don't know that they would have
looked at it from an angle where they could easily see it cuz
I think when the I think when the hilt is on it actually isn't
that obvious. So why did none of them say that? Why is that why
is a single H have any of them just said, "Oh, it was a misunderstanding.
I didn't I didn't know it could be seen that way." Because I
don't think they think it's a swastika. I think they think they
have a justification. And by the way, it's a total culture war.
They're they're just going to say, "Yeah, I nope, not a swastika."
They're never going to give you anything because nobody's going
to be good faith with them. Why would they ever give anything
up? Okay, they can they're Are they Are they Are Froggen and
Shondaanda Black dog whistling at support for Trump right now?
Um, no. Are they trying to with Ethan by showing that they support
Trump or do they just grab funny props that were sitting around
room? Okay. So, you think they just grab funny props that were
sitting around room and put them on? Um, I think that hat You
don't think they were like, "Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. If
we put this hat on, some people are really going to interpret
us as actual Trump supporters. No, cuz that wouldn't make sense
in this context. This isn't like a debate.
This doesn't make sense in this context.
These are like the furthest people politically align political
alignment wise. These are the f furthest people away from Nazis,
right? Okay. You can still like the anti-semitism part. Okay.
I mean, you you can read anti-semitism into this if you want.
You just look insane. Okay. Okay. You you don't even believe
they're anti-semitic. You think at worst they're just trying
to with Ethan with like a sort of half a like a a deformed swastika
as a sword in a random picture they took and posted to social
media. You don't even think they're actually anti-semitic. You
think they're doing this to mess with Ethan because of a beef,
right? Yeah. Messing with Ethan. Yeah, that's that's why they're
doing Yeah. Okay. So, you don't even think they're anti-semitic?
Not necessarily because of this. Okay. Well, I guess but it's
playing to like a stereotype, I guess. Okay. So it's import They
saw it and they went I guess I would say you're they saw it they
saw it they saw that it looked like a swastika obviously when
you're holding it there and then they or they looked at the picture
were like we're going to post this anyway and then you're trying
to you're trying to basically backwards rationalize it as no
they knew it was a swastika and that's why they won't take the
picture down that's why they won't denounce it. It's like no
they just know that if they actually give in here nobody will
give them any charity and they'll just it'll be used as proof
of their guilt. So, they're just going to say, "No, we no. They
just don't care." Like, okay. Yeah, they definitely don't care
about none of these people. Wait, why would any of these people
care about Ethan? They think Ethan's been on a care. They don't
care about Ethan. They don't care. You're saying they don't care
about anti-semitism.
They have been getting called anti-semitic. They think all of
the people calling them anti-semitic are morons. They've been
getting called anti-semitic for a year and a half. Yeah. They
just don't. So, they don't care about it at all because people
they don't like the people calling them that. No, they think
that people calling them that have no attachment to reality.
So why would they plate them in any way? So then why not? Okay.
So then why would it sounds like then they have no problem with
being anti-Semitic then? Cuz why would we even care to plate?
You're not even arguing that they're anti-Semitic. Don't do I
have to rewind like 30 seconds to where you said yeah. No, I
guess they're not anti-Semitic. I didn't I didn't say that. But
I'm okay. You're saying that because everyone calls them anti-semitic
in bad faith that um they would just would not care at all about
it. and they would basically have no ability to evaluate that
as a real call for or a real accusation of anti-semitism because
one they're not anti-semitic. Two, they probably were unaware.
They might be unaware or they might either they might be unaware
that this could be interpreted as a swastika. Like they might
not have looked at it closely from like top down or they could
have um they could just know it's from bleach and just know that
it's not like a swastika. It's not meant to be anti-mitic at
all. Or like they just grab the sword and they're using it. Like
there's so many so many harmless explanations and we're just
reading in the most malicious one with no evidence whatsoever
other than these people don't like Ethan. I'm sorry. What was
the first thing you said? That it's uh what was it? That um we
don't even know that they looked at it, looked at the sword and
saw that it was anti-semitic. No, you list of explanations. Um
that Yeah, they grabbed it. They didn't know or they know the
bleach story and they don't care, right? Oh, okay. So, okay.
They didn't know. Um
you you understand? They would never that if you were to like
if you were to use like a really bad word or something that was
a good word. Let's say somebody from Spain comes to America and
they they say the word black in Spanish, right? And people get
very angry at them. The the thing isn't to go, "Oh yeah, you're
right. I was like totally being racist or I I could see how you'd
be racist. Sorry." It's to say that's the cucked version. Okay.
What you say is no. In my language, this is the color and now
I know I probably won't do it again, but I'm not going to apologize
cuz I had no no uh bad intent there. Why would I apologize? I
didn't do anything bad. Um, you at least acknowledge that there
was a misunderstanding. They don't have they ever done that or
have they just said, "Yeah, based." I don't know. Okay. Did Did
somebody go actually you guys are using a swastika sword? And
one of them went, "Yeah, cuz it's based." Yeah, that was the
whole Death Note thing. Like, yeah, I was doing it to troll Ethan.
He didn't say it was based. He said that's the most argument
on planet Earth. He was mocking you. You understand that he is
mocking you with the Death Note thing, right? You understand?
He is saying you are doing but as a joke because it's so crazy.
Yes. Okay, good. I just wasn't sure that you understood because
you just said that. He said no. It was bass. He said no. You'd
have to be a 30 IQ mouth breathing to think this. That's the
whole point of the bit. Yeah, but he never actually says he's
not. He just says that, oh, it's so crazy. Ethan's so crazy.
That's all he can say. No, he's saying everybody accusing him
is so crazy. He's saying everybody saying here's how I got the
sword. It's [__] insane to that I got the sword for
any purpose of antise-semitism. Yes, I that's Yes. But he doesn't
actually deny or he never actually says oh it was a misunderstanding.
What is the obvious implication where he mocks everybody saying
this? You understand there is an implication but he's like you
guys are for thinking this. Right? If I tell you you're for thinking
something you're like yeah but you're not saying you didn't do
it. It's like no I am. That's implied by my argument. You're
completely for thinking this. That is implied by my argument.
Yes, you're you I'm I didn't do that. You would be lying. You
would be lying like openly and blatantly if it was the other
way, right? If he if he did mean to do this and then uh that
would just be like a lie because then he is actually using it
for anti-semitism. Okay, Porter Bell, you got to chill. You got
to chill. Son would lie. That's crazy. Okay. I mean, just all
you all you guys have to do is decide whether or not you want
to look insane to most normies or like this is the kind of thing
where um is this an argument? Why do I care? I don't care about
where I look to other people. I'm just I'm talking about what
it actually is. Yeah, but you already agreed it's not actually
anti-semitic. I said it was okay. I said the point of it was
to play on the stereotype that Ethan is uh obsessively paranoid
about
which I think I would probably say that you're playing into anti-semitism
into that. No. No. No. If you're being if you're being completely
histrionic, I can laugh at you. Sorry. If you are being completely
insane about anti-semitism, if you are seeing Jew haters behind
every corner, I will make fun of you. You deserve to be made
fun of. I don't have to plate your insane fantasies about anti-semitic
people coming to burn down your house. I don't have to do that.
That's not a rule, okay? And I will do that. If you're being
insane, I'm sorry. I'm going to call you out and laugh at you.
That's not anti-semitism. Laughing at people who are completely
hallucinating anti-semitism is not in itself anti-semitism. That's
stupid. Yeah. Then you're okay. You're saying he's doing that
thing. He's doing the thing. Okay. I gave you my position. But
then Okay, then why did you say any of that? Because he's not.
So why did you just say all of that? Because you said if you
don't care about somebody thinking it's anti-semitic, then you're
anti-semitic. That was what you said. They don't care that Ethan
You're playing into the stereotype of Ethan seeing anti-semitism
where where it isn't. And I'm like, okay, maybe. And you were
like, okay, well, if they don't care that he sees it as anti-semitism,
then that's anti-semitic. That was like what you said. He doesn't.
All right. You're arguing that if somebody's going, "Hey, I think
that's anti-Semitic." And if you do anything other, basically,
this is the world you want is that somebody, no matter how insane,
could say, "You're being anti-Semitic right now." And you have
to go, "Oh, I'm very sorry, sir. I would never do any I would
never say anything bad about Jews. Doesn't matter if you're just
like eating spaghetti." It's like, whoa, the way you're holding
that fork is an anti-Semitic canard. Oh, you're right. You're
right. You're right. I'm so sorry for doing that, Mr. Juicer.
I will uh I will, you know, I'll use chopsticks for my spaghetti
from now on. You think it's completely unreasonable to think
that uh you think that's like the level of uh prison that Ethan
has? It's just like the like it's just completely like grasping
his straws for every single thing. This one? Yeah, this one is
definitely grasping his straws 100%. Okay. Like you think everything
is okay. This the swastika like it's it's like the again not
a swastika just what you think most people would interpret as
a swastika despite being explained what it actually is. So I
went 100% of people I want to be like 100% of people interpret
that as a swastika. 95% of people in the west would interpret
that as a swastika. Um after being explained to like what it
is and how it is not a swastika clearly and it's like a part
of Japan and that culture and like they use that symbol in a
lot of things. I I feel like most people go oh actually okay
gotcha. But this has nothing none this what does Japan have to
do with any of this though? Why would that matter? It has to
do with the underlying fact of the matter, which is important
to whether or not you're dog whistling. No, I'm saying what they're
communicating. Why would What does Buddhism have anything to
do with the message they're communicating? They're not I don't
think they're trying to communicate a message. Oh, you're arguing
you're arguing that they're that them that you reading something
in that I don't believe that they're actually trying to say.
You're arguing that they should apologize for your reading of
this, right? They don't have to apologize. They could just deny
it. I I'm sure at least one of them has said it's not a swastika.
Have Have not at least one of them said it's not a swastika?
I feel like at least one of them would have gone it's not a swastika
or something or it's from bleach. That is denying it.
Um no. Okay. I guess like you would say that there's a misunder
you would say that there's a misunderstanding. I didn't interpret
it as a swastika. Have any of them said that? I don't know. Okay.
That's weird. Why Why would Isn't that pretty easy to say? Would
that just be the only thing? Why do they have to say that? make
the argument for why they have to say that. Um, they could not
and just be seen as the argument for why they don't care about
that. No, no, don't tell me they have to tell me they're not.
Just make the argument for why they have to say something. If
they're concerned about not looking anti-semitic, then yeah,
you would that would be you just say that and instantly Well,
I mean that would uh deflate it a lot. Yeah. You think nobody's
going to call these four people anti-semitic after they say actually
we didn't realize that that could be interpreted as a swastika
and we're really sorry. You think nobody's gonna call them anti-semitic?
Yeah, a little bit more difficult. I They wouldn't call I I would
be surprised if people more difficult. Would it really be a little
more difficult? I would be surprised if after they said like,
"Oh, I didn't intend for this to be a swastika." That people
would say and they, you know, took out the image or whatever.
I would be surprised if people would still attack them over that.
No, people would absolutely still attack them over that. Look,
they admitted it. They they themselves admitted that it was anti-Semitic
and that it could be interpreted that way. There's no there's
no like justified reason to actually engage with the other side
when they're doing something that's like mind readading like
this. There is there's no benefit. I personally would if I if
any of these people ask me for like hey how should I respond
to this? I'd say don't respond to it. If they don't care then
what's there to even say then? They just don't care about looking
anti-semitic. So then why do they have why would they even complain
about at that point? Why do they have Sorry. Do you Do do you
think that they just don't care about people like maybe their
friends or family thinking they're anti-semitic? Or do you think
they just don't care about extremely like extremely online people
calling them anti-semitic because they've been having that happen
to them for 18 months now? Um, which do you think is more likely?
That they literally don't care about any allegations of anti-semitism
or probably from a certain group of people. They just don't interpret
those as like a meaningful signal. There's just too much noise
there. I'm not going to actually pay attention. Yeah, I guess.
Yeah, they just don't care if Yeah, they don't care if like Ethan
or any like any of those people would uh see them as
They don't. Do you know why? Yeah, there's a reading listening
comprehension quiz. Do you know why they don't care? They're
so bad faith. They'll see it anywhere. They're so bad faith.
No, they're so bad faith. They'll just see it anywhere. Like
the people accusing them. Yeah, basically is how they interpret
it. Now, I would say there's probably a lot better reason to
call them anti-semitic than this sword. But unfortunately, after
you after you repeatedly see anti-semitism everywhere, you call
these people anti-semitic for so long, they're going to stop
caring when you when you get really mad about some little microaggression,
right? And they're not going to care to like try to clear it
up at all.
Um, so they Okay, so they pick the Swasio sword randomly without,
you know, no ideas in their mind about that. Um, for the thing
where they're getting accused of anti-semitism. Okay, my question,
why would you play into it then? Or I guess it would just be
like a total accident and you wouldn't care about you're playing
into it playing into it. Like okay actually like why why would
that even be like a a win? Like when someone accuses you of something
why would you play into it? Feels like a they're playing Wait,
where did they play into it? Hold on. Where did they play into
it? Like what the saying? Yes. That there's no intent going into
using the sword. That's my argument. It's up to you to prove
intent. You have not sufficiently proven intent.
You say that like there's just you're saying that like okay you're
proof that there's no intent is that they're just they there's
like they might be the 0% of Americans that like just cannot
possibly understand how it's a swastika and then when people
see it they just are so blind to the criticism of
person they just can't see it like like I could totally see how
this does not look like a swastika right when it's this resolution
you see what the resolution is you can't really tell what it
is right like do you think it's not possible that nobody really
looked that closely at the sword in person. Yes, the sword. Were
they taking the picture or the full resolution picture when they
took it and uploaded it? It's possible they just didn't know.
Yeah, it's possible they just didn't look at it. They just took
it blindly. They put a like what?
Well, obviously they looked at the picture blindfolded. So, I'm
guessing you could at least see the sword that he's holding.
Maybe. Yeah. But do you think they're looking at the sword or
you think they're just generally looking at like the their faces
and to make sure none of them are blinking and Oh, we got a good
picture. Let's go. Okay. I'm sorry. Yeah, my bad. He could have
just like completely closed his eyes, not picked up the sword
or sorry, he could have closed his eyes, picked up the sword,
never seen it the entire time, never looked at the picture. I
guess he could have. He's not technically looking at the sword.
What? Oh, my It's not my Discord. That's the problem. No, I said
I'd be right back. Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't hear that. I heard
what you said, but um yeah, I said I'd be right back. Like I
mean you can you can do that ridiculous hypothetical but then
I I can just do it on the other side and say okay so you think
these people who Idubbbz specifically has given up millions of
dollars likely right millions of dollars trying to deedge his
channel trying to make it he doesn't even want to say he doesn't
want to say the n-word he doesn't want to like curse excessively
he doesn't want to make people feel bad but in this one case
he's actually going to use a swastika to try to menace a Jew
or try to make a Jew look insane that's that's where the line
is I mean he also did the content cop the He said that was just
so horrible that he couldn't do it not even to Leafy. Wait, do
you understand this is a totally different version of content
cop, right? Like why when in the past has he ever shown like
where he was like kind of wrong with the the Kirkonda thing and
then he like showed himself crying with Kirk?
How is that a part of how is that not him doing a totally different
He didn't want to do content cop the same way and he didn't do
it the same way. Right. Okay. his his problem with the content
cop the idea of like harshly criticizing someone uh harshly
criticiz hypocrite they're like a loser and yeah trying to make
them look like awful but he he basically said that's like the
not the idea this time that's why he included footage of him
like crying and talking about Ethan and like he took like a totally
different tack on this right I think basically everybody agrees
he took a totally different tack on this like it's not content
comp it's not the same series it was like a a playing on the
the old memes and then he basically did a totally different type
of video. I guess maybe I think his criticism of Content Cop
would apply to this one cuz they were incredibly broad. Oh, okay.
Yeah. I don't Is it really that like I don't know. I mean, this
whole video the whole video against Ethan was pretty pretty mean.
So, I can believe the IDubs is pretty mean.
Really? Have you watched uh have you watched any Red Bar content
on uh Ethan Klein or Helilocline? Red Bar. I don't know what
that is. No, I just You think this is mean? I feel like this
is not remotely mean. This is like This is like mean for like
the most the most like SJW sphere of YouTube. This is like their
version of mean. This not actually mean. None of them called
Ethan like uh None of them like mocked Ethan's looks as far as
I know. Did Idubs mock Ethan's looks in this? Okay. I'm sorry.
I I don't know when. Okay. What was mean? Where's like the mean-spirited
bits? Just where's the mean-spirited bits? It's like it's the
it's the um what would you call it? Like the backhanded
everything. It's like the really snarky, mean, bitter, annoying,
like woman kind of mean. Not the scream at you slurs kind of
mean. Archangel, you're being a [__] in chat right
now. I do not have to prove that this wasn't intentional. You
have to approve or give me some evidence that it is intentional.
You're making a positive claim. I'm not making a positive claim.
Uh yeah, this this sword this sword is like basically like a
there's um like a sp like a squared spiral symbol here. Um it
is like a more obvious, you know, closer to a swastika looking
in the anime or in the manga. And there are other elements of
it in the manga that look like more swastika-esque. Yeah, hold
on. I should be able to find Where's the tweet here? Somebody
linked me the tweet. What did I do with it? Hold on. Let me find
this tweet really quickly. But if I if I can just find like the
um yes, the the hilt of this the guard I guess the guard of this
sword is like meant to be a swastika. It looks way way more like
this in the anime. The sword I think that has is not quite that
bad or doesn't quite look like this but he's got like other clips.
There are other clips of him using it. You' to bet $100 which
is more likely. They pose for the photo and no one notices swastika
or they pose for it like haha this will mess with Ethan. Haha.
Um, if I had to bet $100, I think I would bet on haha, this will
mess with Ethan from one of them. But I don't think there was
like an an agreement in the room. We'll all mess with Ethan.
I think maybe one person might have noticed it. If you're asking
me if like Idubbbz specifically noticed it, I would say I would
probably bet he did not notice it personally. Um, he might decide
not to do anything about it after the fact, but I I don't believe
he he noticed it. I think that's like sort of antithetical to
like most of the changes he's tried to make. By the way, the
content cop video was almost entirely was almost entirely like
badly put together. It was really really [__] Okay.
It was just totally dog. All right. Sure. This is the this is
the one. So like it's the same thing here. There's like definitely
angles you can look at this and not see it because it's like
just a cheaper knockoff sword, right? Well, but knows this was
obviously. Yes. But I mean he knows he picked it up on this and
but Ian didn't. I guess what is this here? If it's not big, then
please show us. I mean, that seems to be what it looks like,
but that Yeah, that looks very different. Like, I get how you'd
say that that's a But I mean, it's it's I just don't think it's
really a swastika. I don't think like if it was really swastika,
someone would bought it. Yeah, I understand that he has that
he knows that there's like you could interpret it that way. Aren't
you Aren't you mind reading him against his own words? Sorry,
what? You're saying like, well, he wouldn't have bought it if
he actually thought it was a swastika one. But even though he
called it that, he doesn't actually think it like he doesn't
think it's if he thought it was like a a genuine swastika, I
don't think he would have kept that sword. I don't think he would
have bought it. Like he would have had that explained to him.
He would understand what it what it means that it's something
different. And you go, "Ha, that's funny." But he still owns
it and he called it the swastika one. So that happened and he
didn't get rid of it. Uh, hold on. Schle, wait. He said, "Why
are you arguing that Idubbbz is not trying to be edgy in the
pick when there are two people in Trump hats?" Uh, because I
just don't think that these people would try to use like a like
Idubbbz could have showed up in a Nazi outfit, right? Like you're
just I don't know. You're reading intentin that I just I need
to see proof of it. Well, okay. Because the only alternative
is like insane. The only alternative is that they didn't care
or didn't know like this. You understand? They didn't care because
they didn't care. That's This is what it looks like, right? This
is what it looks like perfectly from top down. You think there
aren't angles where you like can't really tell what this is and
you was okay. You're that like that's every angle that he looked
at it when he held it and posed for a picture. Yes. Yes. You
understand you're making a positive claim, right? You're making
a positive claim. You have to prove it in some way, but you don't
want to prove it, right? You you just want to signal. You just
want to point out the question that what is the other
that they didn't think about care about it? I don't Is it even
a positive claim? It's just like out of all the interpretations,
which one is most likely and you're saying, well, it could be
any other one. Same argument you made earlier for why you wouldn't
buy that sword applies to for the same reason. Has never had
credible accusations of anti-semitism only. And when he bought
the sword, he definitely had no credible accusations of anti-semitism
from anybody. He was best friends with Ethan at the time.
Oh, you think I should make this my avatar for the stream? I'm
good. Dan equals Dan does equal when it comes to seeking anti-semitism.
Did you watch none of my streams with him where I had to talk
him down every single time and say, "Dan, this is not them being
insane. Dan, this is not them being anti-semitic. Dan, this is
not them being anti-semitic. Dan, you are going way over the
top here. Dan, you need to reel it back in, Dan." How many How
many streams did I do with Dan where I where I'm like trying
to reel him back in all the time?
How many times did I need to do that for you to understand that
I thought Dan was being performative and over the top? How many
times?
Uh, I guess you could make the argument that we can't ever read
their No, you can you can read their minds, but then I'm going
to say like, okay, what do we know about these people? Oh, they
like basically preach against Nazism. They basically their entire
ideology is around like being anti-Nazi, anti-fascist. Okay,
well then probably that's that's where I would land on that,
right? If I go and look at their ideology to in totality, they're
totally anti-fascist. They're totally anti-Nazi. I Okay, that's
very easy for me to go, well, no, I don't think it's a dog whistle.
No, I don't think there's anti anti-semitism at play here. At
worst, you could say they maybe trying to with Ethan, but I don't
know that, and I'm not going to read that in because I don't
need to. Whatever you're fidgeting with, stop. There's a lot
of clicking going on. I'm sorry. Yeah, I don't. Okay. Can you
okay tell me what's like the more reason what's the more likely
thing to happen besides Ian picking up and immediately knowing
noticing it's a swastika thing um literally the opposite
noticing I think it's far more likely okay and like no one noticing
including Hassan who well I guess he could secretly not be there
just hiding in the other room and then when uploading that Hassan
was never involved either I have no idea I don't know if Hassan
cared I don't know what Hassan was thinking about I have no idea
Right. Well, it has to be that, right? Why? Because if involved
at all, then he notices. Oh, yeah. The swastika sword. Wait,
do you Okay. Do you think he would let them know or do you think
he like then what if Okay, that's funny actually. And didn't
let any of them know that it could be interpreted as a swastika
then who all doing the thing that but I'm sure sure. But then
what if it didn't notice that? What if it wasn't in the room?
What if there's a cameraman in the room who's taking that picture?
Okay. and not involved. Who's anti-Semitic here?
Um, probably still them after they receive that pretty obvious
criticism and they're like, "Well, I'm going to sorry, I'm going
to blind myself cuz I hate Ethan so much and I'm just going to
engage with it at all cuz they hate Ethan so much." Okay. I I
just like the 1% chance that's even like it's so like it's just
obviously. How else would you interpret it looking at it? Like
not like none of those people in the room saw this. Very unlikely.
I Yeah, I like I'm telling you they probably didn't I They probably
grabbed a sword off of the rack there. Which which sword was
it on the rack, by the way? Like we see uh Let me pull up the
picture here. Where's Where's the actual picture? Here it is.
Let me pull up the actual picture here. So, we pull this up.
Okay, we pull this up like this. Which sword was it? Where was
it? Did they have to like reach to find it or something? I need
to shut my phone off or something. Oh, no, I don't. I'll just
move it. Okay. Sorry. Um, yeah. So, I just Yeah, I don't know.
Like, where did they reach to get it? Like, they could have easily
just grabbed any sword off of here, not notice the hilt, grabbed
it, pulled it out, not really looked at the hilt, just like posed,
taken a picture, put it back. It's a curated vid. The prop mattered.
Okay, you guys are you guys are going to die in this hill. I
prove to me that that mattered to them. Prove to me that that
was a big deal if they pulled that out. It's not that it it's
not that it has to be a big deal. It's just that like you're
saying that it has to be that every single one of them no one
noticed in the entire chain of events. I didn't say that. I said
who did not say that. That's the only way it was a big deal.
No, I said who did notice? And who do you claim is anti-Semitic
here? Who did it? Like you're you're claiming You're claiming
they all noticed and they all have like something to do. I'm
saying one of them could have seen it. One of them could have
seen it. What? They could have just gone, "Oh, it's the bleach
sword." Not really thought about it, right? I don't think every
person sees that sword after basically having this argument one
time and goes, "Oh, that's super anti-semitic or that's like
a swastica. That's a dog whistle. Don't do that." I think most
people after they have this argument, like when people who are
like 25 watch Bleach for the first time, they're like, "Oh my
god, is that a swastika?" And then somebody like they look it
up, they're like, "Oh, no, it's not." Then they probably just
never think about it again, right? They Yeah. They just delete
the idea that it could be a swastika from their mind. Yeah. Like
they they've now resolved that in their brain. They don't care.
What if Nick Fentes had that sword? It would be way different
because Nick Fuentes is like an avowed Hitler supporter. It would
be infinitely different obviously. Okay. Uh we're looping on
the same thing. So if you don't have any new points to raise,
I just you're making a positive claim. You're mind reading them
and you reading these hat. I'm pretty sure you're the only one
making a positive claim or no none of them would be positive.
There are no positive claims here. Yes, they you're saying you
have to assert that no you're saying they did this knowingly
and intentionally. Yes. Um yeah, I guess so. Yeah, that is a
positive claim. Thank you. Sure. You have to Okay. In order to
say that, okay, for for it not to be intentional, no one would
have to notice it, right? They would have to not they would have
to do it not knowingly, right? They they would have to they would
have to notice it. They would have to notice it and then they
would have to go, "Okay, this is like um something I can't do
here." So again, so Okay, wait. So, okay. There was like a 1%
chance that they noticed it and like didn't make the connection
at all. Shooting. Oh, more video shooting with swords. I guess
Hassan just loves samurai swords. Damn. I'm just I I'm saying
I don't know how long they took this picture. I don't know how
long they had the picture the sword out. I don't know what happened
here. So, I'm saying if you get more information that's fine,
but the idea that it's a dog whistle or that they're actually
anti-semitic is insane, right?
It's like the most like
Okay. Uh let's see. Let's see if we can find a par like a a parallel
here really quickly. Um something that you think could be interpreted
as anti or racist. Let's say that they came in with uh this I
don't know if this is a good one. Um no, I need to f I need to
find something that could be racist, but it's not. And then like
it just seems to me that if you know what it is, then you don't
really think about it anymore. Um so it's it is what it is. Like
I I just think there's more people delete the idea that it could
possibly be interpreted as a swastika to anyone. Here's here's
the proof that he deleted the idea. He used the sword in another
promo. If he was thinking, if his first thought when he looked
at this sword was, it's a swastika sword. Why would he use it
for promoting a samurai game? Wouldn't that look really stupid?
Wouldn't he look like a complete I I don't know. That's obvious.
This is obviously very close to proof that does not actually
think that this is a at all that he that he doesn't think about
it that way. That he just pulled the sword out and he did a promo
with it. He doesn't think he doesn't notice that aspect of it
at all. He deleted that from his mind. That that basically doesn't
come up to him anymore. He's probably had this argument once
or twice and he's like, "It's not as I know it's not." Yeah.
It just doesn't mind. Okay. No, you obviously know that when
you when you know information about something like Hold on. Who's
who do you consume the most content from? Destiny. Okay. Perfect.
I actually thought you were going to say Toro or something, but
Perfect. So, when when Destiny says like a slur or the N-word
or something, um, sometimes those just come out without him thinking,
right? He can be in the middle of an argument. I've heard him
drop an F-sler before, right? Do you think Do you think he intentionally
is going, "Okay, so I'm going to use the Fler here because I
know that there are people who will hear this who are going to
be with or do you think it's just something that like he's sort
of like because he grew up with it, it sort of loosened in his
mind like where he should have it and like that, right? This
isn't like he he didn't drop an accidental gamer word. He like
made a promotion, right? That would show that would be like way
worse. That would be like way worse. This is like something he
could miss. I'm saying that obviously the how offensive something
is to somebody else goes away completely in your mind if it's
normalized for you. And as a Destiny viewer, you should be incredibly
incredibly aware of this fact. Okay, you're saying okay that
comparison okay that comparison isn't like you do you forget
something for like half a second and like you say something you
don't it's like it just you're talking about an entire process
of making promotional material for video. So you either have
to say that thinks it's a swastika sword and anybody who picked
the sword up would see it's a swastika sword and they'd have
to deal with that and reckon with that and then you're saying
use that swastika sword because he just w Hitler. No, I already
gave you the
other why did he use the sword? Why did he use the sword? I've
told you like 25 times. Because the point is to uh sorry the
point is to make uh sorry the point is to bait Ethan. Make him
look like he's like paranoid. Are you not in the presentation?
I have this samurai picture up. Why is using the swastika sword
in this picture if it's easily identifiable that it's a swastika?
To most people would look like a swastika, including in mind.
So you're saying that is intentionally dog whistling a swastika
here? No, because the context is different. So you're saying
that because it's a samurai thing, he went, you know what? Um,
now I can use the Nazi symbol that everybody thinks is a Nazi
symbol because it's a samurai thing. Sure. Yeah, that's what
you're claiming. I guess I mean it doesn't really like his state
of mind here doesn't matter. I guess it does matter because you're
saying no no including to Yeah. Yeah. Basically you're saying
he is doing W Hitler here. He knows he's dog whistling. He knows
it and he doesn't care. Why I keep saying no I'm not saying that
because the argument you're making is that it's so obvious to
anybody who would see the sword especially that they would know
that it's inappropriate to use it in any context where it can
be deemed as anti-semitic. Right. But when is there a when is
there a swastika context that's not anti-semitic? So then why
is he using it here would be my question.
Genuinely probably here and he just Yeah, it's like an anime
sword. But okay. All right. I don't need to argue any further.
Thank you. That's I mean that's it's over at that point, right?
No, because he's not this isn't like him. This isn't him criticizing
Ethan who's the guy who criticized him for anti-semitism.
So him he was like you know what swastikas when I'm you're basically
arguing that when he sees Ethan he sees a histrionic Jew and
not like his best friend who kind of betrayed him. Yeah, that's
what he says constantly on stream when he's like crashing out.
He's so crazy. Yeah, obviously you think he's saying he's a histrionic
Jew. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Is you not Is there a reason why you don't
think that? Um because there's nothing like about him that's
been like truly anti-Semitic. Is it him? There there's like a
whole argument around here that you're probably not intelligent
enough to engage with about why you might be able to treat him
like he's anti-Semitic in some cases, but like I just don't think
most people are intelligent enough or understand the politics
of the region or politics to engage with any of the arguments
around it. And so it's just like pretty much I I feel like the
conversations reach this conclusion. You Okay. Okay. Do you think
um Give me a moment. Okay.
I'm sorry. Wonder if this guy thinks Destiny was dog whistling
with the okay symbol with Turkey Tom. Um I have no idea, dude.
It's It's all such a weird It's all weird. Okay, it's all weird.
Also, I didn't have my Twitch open. Guys, don't forget to join
the Twitch. twitch.tv/jc with an underscore. Okay, it's pinned
in the top of the chat. Join up on the Twitch as well. You hear
my voice twice and this guy's voice twice. Okay, thank you. Okay.
You don't think that Okay, sorry. I just I don't think there's
much else to say here. Um I think other people want to argue.
You think that Okay. Okay. You don't think that the uh the context
of Ethan's main like giant criticism of him being anti-semitic
doesn't matter at all? That's not not unless it's done in good
faith and is like extremely see it's in bad faith and then I
Okay, I'm talking about how sees it, right? Sees it as being
in bad faith. He's like extremely anti-racist, anti-fascist.
He thinks people calling him a Nazi or anti-Smittic are insane.
Okay. So, um Okay, he can say that, but does he So, then he's
completely unconcerned with looking that way. How would that
that doesn't prevent like that? Just had this argument already.
I don't want to circle, but I'll just respond really quickly.
Like the answer was he's been getting called anti-Semitic with
things that are like totally benign for 18 months. He is not
going to concern himself with the same group of people calling
him anti-Semitic again over something that when he did it over
here nobody called him anti-Semitic. He's not going to concern
himself because he is not a permanently online loser. Um he is
potentially Yes. This is the actual problem with people calling
everything racist or everything anti-semitic or everything whatever,
right? Is you do actually start to blur the lines on where these
things are. So you should be fairly precise with your words,
right? Um now if if they wanted to say I think a far more salient
critique of is something like hey um a lot of your stuff basically
lands you in the same camp as anti-semites that's like a much
more complex argument and would have to reckon with that but
you just call him anti-semitic he knows he's not anti-semitic
he knows his own mind he can immediately shut that down as he's
done he can so if he believes he's not anti-semitic so he will
never address the criticism of anyone because of that he would
probably address like I guarantee you he would walk through these
arguments with a ton of people. It's just like certain people
on Twitter he's probably not really he's probably done engaging
with them, right? But he's never has he ever but he's never done
that. Uh no, I I feel like he would with somebody who wasn't
trying to like I'm sure he'd go talk to Sam Cedar if Sam Cedar
had credible allegations of anti-semitism for him. Well, okay.
So, you can just say every single person that he doesn't like,
he wouldn't do it for them, but he would do it for someone he
already agrees with. Yeah, sure. But I mean, there is there is
some point where like people will not engage with you in good
faith, right? They'll just always be extremely bad faith about
the things you're saying, which is a weird thing on his own using
the word bad faith. But he's never on his own uh criticized himself
or like thought for me like hm maybe I should think about the
ways I'm being anti-semitic and prevent that. But he's not being
anti-semitic. Where has he been anti-semitic? Okay. You're saying
that he is he will never engage with criticism of him. You just
said he's anti-semitic. I'm telling you, tell me he's been anti-semitic.
You're saying that he is blind to anyone's accusations of it
and he's in he's blinding himself and he will never think about
himself or anyone else's criticism but he might think it's someone
good faith criticizing him but there's no one who can because
he's cut himself off from everyone else. You could argue that
once those criticisms come out like he'll label them as bad faith.
I think this is a tactic he does but I'm saying that right now
like this stuff harms more than it helps in my opinion. this
stuff is you guys going ahead and like freaking the out over
these uh over like this and realistically like probably what
you should be hammering on is his support for like actual terrorist
groups because he hates Israel so much, right? That's like a
way better critique, but you guys have made it already. So now
you're just like thirsty for whatever whatever thing you can
get. So you're bringing up like sword now. Okay. doesn't Okay.
What does that have to do with Okay. You're saying that um he
will never criticize himself for or never no one can criticize
him for anti-semitism. And you're saying people could criticize
him. I'm saying that if people were doing a lot of criticism
of him, he'll probably start discounting it and being bad faith
himself. Okay. That's likely how I see how
to I'm not saying he can't be anti-semitic. I'm saying he doesn't
see himself as anti-semitic. And I'm asking you to tell me where
he's been anti-Semitic if you want to actually put that label
on him. I think this Okay. The sword thing will obviously be
interpreted that way.
Okay. So you are saying that no the sword is obvious knows the
sword's a dog whistle and he is clearly dog whistling towards
anti-semitism here because he is anti-semitic. Um I think his
point is to try to trigger Ethan as I said with the Creed promo
from
No, not with Creed promo. Okay, you should open the Oh, I might
not be presenting. Hold on. I'm not presenting. Whoops. Okay,
this is the last thing we're doing. But it is the thing. Okay.
So obviously that's I've seen this image. Yeah. Yeah. Obviously
it's insane that you would think right here that because sorry
I think it should be obvious which one I'm talking about because
in the other one it's not holding the sword. So when I talk about
holding the sword and your argument is it should be so obvious
to everybody. So obviously we don't see anti-semitism here. So
I'm just I'm asking you where is where is his anti-semitism?
Show me his anti-semitism. I'm talking Okay. You've made this
allegation that he's anti-semitic. You have you've tried to talk
around it. I want to know why you think he's anti-Semitic. I'm
okay. I I'm not alleged he's anti-semitic, but that's not that
wouldn't be relevant to why it's why he's doing the thing he's
doing. He's doing it because he knows that he's called that and
he thinks it's like a funny troll. Okay. Based on disliking him,
but I I sorry I can't keep going in circles. So, thank you for
coming on. You can come on again if you want, but I'm probably
going to move other people and there's other people who want
to argue. All right. See you.